IT.
EVEN IF THEY DID, IT'S IMMORAL
STILL.
>> Tucker: WE HAVE A BISHOP IN
THE UNITED METHODIST CHURCH.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
SAW THE INTERVIEW WE JUST DID
WITH MR. LOPEZ AS AN ELECTED
MUNICIPAL LEADER IN TIJUANA.
HE DESCRIBED THE SCENE AND WE
HAVE PICTURES WHERE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS ARE LIVING IN THE OPEN
AIR.
THE CITY OF TIJUANA IS BEING
DISRUPTED BY THIS.
SCHOOLS HAVE CLOSED, ARRESTS
HAVE BEEN MADE.
FOR SOME IN CASES SERIOUS
CRIMES.
HE SAID THE RECENTLY RELIGIOUS
LEADERS CAME TO THE MIGRANT
ENCAMPMENT AND ENCOURAGED THEM
TO STAY IN TENTS IN THE MIDDLE
OF TIJUANA.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> I'M AWARE THAT RELIGIOUS
LEADERS, AMONG THEM, METHODIST
FROM THE METHODIST CHURCH OF
MEXICO HAVE BEEN COMPASSIONATELY
FEEDING THE MIGRANTS.
I'VE SEEN THEM, I KNOW THEIR
PLIGHT.
THEY'RE MIGRANTS THAT HAVE LEFT
THEIR HOME.
NOT BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO LEAVE
THEIR HOMES BUT BECAUSE THAT
THEY -- POVERTY AND GREAT
VIOLENCE.
SO THEY MIGRATED.
THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO MIGRATE AND
A RIGHT FOR DUE PROCESS FOR
ASYLUM.
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT NEED
HUMANITY TO EXTEND COMPASSION TO
THEM.
LOVE AND CARE.
IT MAY DISCOMFORT SOME, BUT THIS
IS A MOMENT IN WHICH WE CAN SHOW
THE BEST OF HUMANITY.
I'M NOT AWARE OF WHAT WAS JUST
DESCRIBED.
YOU SHOWED PICTURES.
I DIDN'T SEE THEM.
>> Tucker: THAT'S -- RIGHT.
SO ARE WE.
OUR HEART GOES OUT TO ANYBODY
THAT WALKS A GREAT DISTANCE TO
GET A BETTER LIFE.
I ALWAYS ASSUMED THAT MOST
MIGRANTS ARE DECENT PEOPLE.
BUT THERE'S A COST TO THE UNITED
STATES CITIZENS TO EVERY PERSON
THAT COMES HERE.
THE COST IS HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS PER IMMIGRANT OVER A
LIFETIME.
THE METHODIST CHURCH IS NOT
PAYING THAT BILL.
U.S. TAXPAYERS ARE.
SO I WONDER IF THAT'S A FACTOR
IN YOUR CONSIDERATION.
SHOULDN'T YOU BE PAYING FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT YOU ENCOURAGE TO
COME HERE?
WHY AREN'T YOU?
>> MIGRANTS ARE NOT COSTING THIS
COUNTRY IN THE WAY THAT YOU
DESCRIBE.
THESE MIGRANTS THAT COME TO THIS
COUNTRY ARE CONTRIBUTING TO OUR
SOCIETY.
ACTUALLY THEY'RE CONTRIBUTING TO
THE ECONOMIC BASE.
MANY OF THEM ARE PAYING TO OUR
SOCIAL SECURITY AND DON'T
BENEFIT FROM THAT SOCIAL
SECURITY, MONEY THAT THEY'RE
CONTRIBUTING.
MANY ARE WORKING TWO AND THREE
JOBS.
I'VE LIVED AND SERVED IN TEXAS
AND ALL ACROSS THE SOUTHWEST AND
THE WEST.
THESE FOLKS CONTRIBUTE MORE,
MUCH MORE THAN THEY RECEIVE FROM
OUR --
>> Tucker: JUST AS A
MATHEMATICAL -- HOLD ON.
AS A MATHEMATICAL QUESTION,
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
I THINK THERE'S A GREAT MORAL
CONTRIBUTION OF POOR IMMIGRANTS.
I'M NOT ATTACKING THEM
PERSONALLY.
I HOLD NO ANIMUS TOWARDS THEM.
A STUDY HAS BEEN DONE ON IT AND
PEOPLE COME WITH LESS THAN A
HIGH SCHOOL EDUCATION, TAKE MORE
SERVICES BY A HUGE MARGIN THAN
THEY PAY INTO THE SYSTEM.
NOW, YOU DON'T PAY ANY TAXES IN
YOUR CHURCH BECAUSE YOU HAVE A
TAX EXEMPTION.
THE REST OF US WORK FOR
COMPANIES THAT PAY TAXES.
WE'RE SUPPORTING THE POLICIES
YOU'RE ENCOURAGING.
WHY IS IT VIRTUOUS OF YOU TO DO
THAT?
IF YOU'RE ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO
COME HERE, WHY DON'T YOU HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO PROVIDE EDUCATION,
HOUSING, FOOD, MEDICAL BUT YOU
OFFER IT ON TO TAXPAYERS?
WHY IS THAT A CHRISTIAN THING TO
DO?
>> THE UNITED METHODIST --
>> YOUR CHURCH HAS A TAX
EXEMPTION.
>> OUR PEOPLE PAY INTO OUR
SYSTEM AND THEY CONTRIBUTE TO
THE ECONOMIC VIABILITY OF OUR
COUNTRY.
I LIVE AND SERVE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE ECONOMIC AGRICULTURAL BASE
OF CALIFORNIA WOULD JUST
DIMINISH IF NOT BE TOTALLY
UNDERMINED IF IT WASN'T FOR
THESE MIGRANTS --
>> Tucker: HOLD ON.
SINCE YOU'RE A PERSON OF GOD --
>> PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY WON'T
TAKE ON --
>> Tucker: YEAH BUT -- OKAY.
YOU'RE ON THE SIDE OF EMPLOYERS
THAT WANT TO PAY THIRD WORLD
WAGES TO THEIR WORKERS.
THAT'S WHERE YOU ARE IN THIS
QUESTION.
I WANT TO ASK YOU A THEOLOGICAL
QUESTION --
>> I'M NOT ON THE SIDE OF
EMPLOYERS --
>> Tucker: YOU'RE ON THE SIDE --
>> WHO ARE WILLING TO PAY
LESS --
>> Tucker: OF BIG ACC CULTURAL
COMPANIES --
>> THE ECONOMIC STUDIES I'M
READING ARE DIFFERENT FROM THE
ONES THAT YOU ARE QUOTING.
>> Tucker: LET ME ASK YOU A
THEOLOGICAL QUESTION.
THAT IS YOUR AREA OF EXPERTISE.
IF I FORCE YOU TO PUT MONEY IN
THE COLLECTION PLATE IN MY NAME,
WHICH IS WHAT YOU'RE DOING, WITH
U.S. TAXPAYERS, DO I GET THE
CREDIT FROM GOD FOR DONATING TO
THE CHURCH?
IN OTHER WORDS, WHY DON'T YOU AS
A CHURCH MAKE CERTAIN THAT EVERY
PERSON THAT YOU ENCOURAGE TO
COME HERE IS FED AND HOUSED AND
EDUCATED AND HEALED AT YOUR
EXPENSE?
HOW CAN YOU FEEL VIRTUOUS WHEN
YOU'RE NOT PAYING FOR THE THINGS
THAT YOU'RE ENCOURAGING?
I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
>> FIRST OF ALL, WE'RE NOT INCUR
EDGE ARING PEOPLE TO COME.
>> Tucker: YES, YOU ARE.
>> WE'RE TRYING TO HELP THEM
STAY.
WHEN THEY COME BECAUSE THEY HAVE
HIT A DESPERATE PLACE IN THEIR
LIVES, WE'RE GOING TO CARE FOR
THEM, SEEK JUSTICE FOR THEM,
GOING TO ASK FOR --
>> Tucker: DO YOU PAY FOR THEIR
MEDICAL EXPENSES?
ANY OF THEM?
I DON'T THINK YOU DO.
>> WE DO.
>> Tucker: YOU TO?
HOW MUCH DO YOU SPEND A YEAR?
>> WE CARE FOR HOUSING, WE CARE
FOR THEIR CARE.
WE SPEND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AS
UNITED METHODIST AND WE'RE NOT
THE ONLY ONES.
THE CATHOLIC CHURCH --
>> Tucker: AMERICAN TAXPAYERS
SPEND $135 BILLION ON THIS.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE, YOU SHOULD PITCH IN MORE
THAN YOU ARE.
THEN YOU CAN CALL IT VIRTUE.
>> Dana:
>> WE DO PITCH IN TO CARE FOR
THEM IN WAYS BEYOND YOUR